So, what do you do when the customer objects?
You go through the whole thing, you do the Amex or Visa, you do the Assumption close
and the customer says they want to think about it, the customer has to talk to their business
partner, the customer this, the customer that, they got to check their budget, whatever.
We should know what the objections are gonna be and you're probably going, oh crap, I forgot
to hit on that one or I didn't hit on it hard enough and you're gonna know exactly what
you did wrong in that moment.
What do you do?
Okay, well first of all, what you don't do is you don't give up because 99% of sales
people are taught that this is where the deal starts, right?
You got the grant card notes out there, this is where the deal starts, this is the objections,
right?
And it's like, kind of true, but I'm a big believer in just overcoming the objection.
However, you are gonna have times where you forget, you are gonna have times where you
don't do it correctly, you are gonna have times where you've done it so many times you get
lazy and you forget to do, to overcome the objection beforehand.
You forgot to check if they watched the screencast.
You are going to have to deal with objections.
The cool part is because we've focused so much on the setup, the objections are gonna
be minimal.
We're not gonna have to dig through a treasure trove of objections to close this thing, okay?
So I'm gonna do a very basic training on how to handle objections, which we will do more
in-depth training later, but I want you guys to notice something.
Most sales trainings, they would spend majority of their time talking about this part, which
is the objection handling, but I've spent most of my time talking about the setup and
the close because you can just overcome it all there, okay?
However, I do know this happens.
It even happens with me from time to time and it's usually, well, it's not usually,
it is your fault.
You missed a step, okay?
But what do you do?
So I'm gonna go over a quick little training and the first thing that you wanna do is you
have to tie them down, okay?
And I have an entire video that we did, a live stream, and we'll try and link it up
or make it accessible, but we did this entire training on this concept, okay?
First thing that you need to do is you need to tie them down to that objection, okay?
Think of it as you're trying to get them into a corner so you can kill them, right?
Which I know is a little aggressive or a better example maybe of not using something so extreme
is all of the, you're in a house and you want to keep all the air in the house, right?
And every window that's open is an objection.
And in order for you to close the sale, you need to get all the windows closed, right?
And every window is an objection, so you're just going through closed, closed, closed,
closed, but you need to find out which windows are closed and which windows are open.
So first thing you need to do is you need to tie them down.
So here's what I would do is if they say I need to talk to, or let's use a different
example.
That one rarely should come up because you should make sure that the business owner's
partners are on the phone or that they're the decision maker.
That shouldn't come up.
But let's say that they object and say they wanna think about it, which is pretty common,
let me mull this over, let me get back to you.
That's a really common objection.
So here's what you're gonna do is you're gonna say, yeah, and you're gonna say, you're gonna
agree first.
You're gonna go, yeah, I feel you, man, I totally get it.
And you're gonna tie them down.
You're gonna go, so let me just ask you this and then, this will be really quick, let me
just ask you this and then we'll hop off, because I don't want them to feel like we're
getting into battle mode, right?
So I'll say, besides just thinking about it, is there any other questions, does anything
else, besides just like the fact of thinking about it, anything else that doesn't make
sense, like assuming you think about it and it makes sense, like is there any other reason
that you wouldn't wanna move forward with this today, okay?
And you have to tie them down.
Because if you don't, then there could be multiple objections.
This could be what they call a smoke screen.
It's not the real objection, right?
So what you're gonna find is when you say that, sometimes they'll go, well, I mean,
I need to think about it, but also I need to check with my partner.
And you go, oh, I forgot that one too.
So now you got two.
So okay, all right, so besides thinking about it and besides talking to your partner, is
there any other reason or any other question of why this wouldn't make sense today, why
you wouldn't wanna move forward today?
Nope, that's it, okay?
And now you can start digging in.
But what we've done is we've taken all that list of objections and we've eliminated all
the other ones and we've narrowed it down to one or two, okay?
So in this example, I'm gonna just share if you've got one objection, because if you guys
are doing this correctly, you should have no objections and if you miss a step, you
should have only one.
But I'm gonna just assume this person just wants to think about it, okay?
And so then what you're gonna wanna do is dig in a little bit and be like, so if you
don't mind me asking, what exactly do you wanna think about?
Because to me, everything sounds like it makes sense.
And listen, okay?
Don't let it sound salesy, don't put pressure, but listen to what they say.
What exactly do you wanna think about, okay?
And they're gonna tell you, they're gonna say.
And then you're gonna listen and look at cues and try to pick up on what they're actually
saying, not just the words that are coming out of their mouth, okay?
So you're gonna tie it down.
You're gonna ask a follow-up question or two about that objection.
Maybe it's a spouse.
Okay, what exactly do you need to talk to your partner about, right?
Do you need his blessing, her blessing?
Is he the actual decision-maker?
Am I talking to the wrong person?
You can do a little pride game there.
Dig into it, okay?
And then you're gonna use the magic feel felt found, okay?
It's a three-step process.
So as I said before, we want to agree.
So they're gonna say, yeah, I just wanna make sure that this is the right decision, right?
Because it's like 2,000 bucks, I just wanna make sure it's a good decision, right?
Yeah, I feel you, man.
I feel you, ma'am, ma'am, man.
I feel it.
You're gonna agree first.
I totally understand.
I feel you, okay?
That's it.
Just say, I feel you.
Just let them know you understand.
Then what you're gonna do is you're gonna use an example, and this is why it's really
important to have a bunch of examples in your back pocket, which we'll get into later.
You're gonna use an example of one of your clients, okay?
And this could be one of my clients, one of somebody else's clients, or one of your own
clients, and that's why you need to have a pocketbook full of these, a Rolodex full of
these.
You're gonna say, funny that you say that, do you remember that guy Brooks that I was
showing you earlier, the Bentonville Concord guy?
Yeah, I remember him.
Okay, he, when we talked, and again, this has been a couple years ago, he felt the exact
same way.
We talked, and everything looked right, and he's just like, dude, I just want to think
about it.
So, just so you know, I'm with you, okay?
So Phil felt, right?
Brooks, it's way different than if you say, yeah, man, I get you.
I felt the same way, blank, right?
You, of course you felt the same way, and you're gonna try and convince them, but when
it's Brooks, when it's the client, it's totally different, it's a third party, right?
So yeah, you remember Brooks, yeah, he felt the exact same way.
That comes to step three, which is what he found, so you're gonna go, yeah, but after
we talked about it, and I asked him, Brooks, what do you want to think about, what he found,
or what he realized, doesn't need to be those exact words, but what he realized is that
he was already paying for Google Ads, he wanted exclusive leads, he was tired of the leads
being pimped out, and that there was really no risk, because even if I only, if I just
sent him 10 leads, or 12 leads, he was gonna at the very least double his money.
And so, what he ended up doing, he's like, dude, really it's just me being, like, putting
off the inevitable, so let's do it.
So Brian, you know this makes sense, you've seen the case studies, you already told me
that I'm not full of crap, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, let's do the deal, man.
Are you an Amex or Visa?
Let's quit messing around, okay?
And you're gonna go back for the close, okay?
I know that might sound scary, but you know what's more scary is being broke.
You know what's more scary is getting off the call and missing out on a $2,000 per month
deal, a $24,000 per year deal that you could have gotten by just saying one line that was
a little bit uncomfortable for you in that moment.
And I understand, I'm not that aggressive, but I get it, I get it, but guess what, get
used to being uncomfortable once in a while, because you're gonna have to get uncomfortable
to be comfortable.
You know what's comfortable is using that $2,000 to sip my ties on the beach in Mexico
and have people rub cocoa butter on your belly while you're reading a book, okay?
That's comfortable.
But you're gonna have to use a little bit of, you're gonna have to go through a little
bit of discomfort sometimes to get to the comfortable.
So what I do in these moments when I'm like, oh, this is gonna be awkward, I start thinking
about, hey, this might be a little awkward, I'm not comfortable.
I wouldn't choose to do this on my spare time, but you know what, this is that hour
I psyched myself up before, this is where I need to meet business, and I need to get
to business, and it might be a little uncomfortable, and it might be a little, but guess what,
I want the money more than I care about the discomfort, than I wanted to avoid the discomfort,
and I'll say it.
I'll go, look, Brian, let's just talk real here.
You know you need to do this, and there's not another option out there like this.
Everything checks the boxes.
What card are we putting on file, man, let's not mess around, okay, come on, come on, man.
You already know the answer.
You know that the second we get off this call, you already know the answer, okay.
You can put this off as long as you want, and you also know that, and guys, this is
the beautiful part, is we've already told them if we've done this correctly, well, some
of you guys might not have, and that might be why they wanna think about it, right, but
if we've done this correctly, we can remind them, hey, I already told you, I have a call
in an hour, right, I would like to do the deal with you, so, and again, make sure to
have the no fear of loss.
Look, at the same time, I wanna do this, I wanna work with you, if it doesn't make sense,
I'll work with them, but I know this makes sense, so, what's the card, man?
Let's do this, okay, what's the card, man?
Be bold, so, just to recap, really, really quick, okay, tie them down, make sure that's
the objection and the only, okay, ask a few follow-up questions to understand the objection,
then you're gonna use the Phil felt found method, and you're gonna go back for the close,
that's it.